this brief scuba diver is recording
sailfish hunting a school of sardines in
order to capture such a scene
researchers spent days on a boat
following frigate birds to pray in
groups as small as four or as large as
70 the fish take turns slashing or
poking the sardine school with their
toothy bills after an attack one fish
will take a break while another takes a
shot
the researchers learned from these
recordings that only 24% of attacks
ended in a sardine snack but 95% ended
up with an injury to a member of the
sardine school injured sardines quickly
tire putting them more at risk of
getting snapped up by one of the selfish
crowd it turns out this is a simplistic
but efficient form of group hunting for
example individuals do not assume
specific roles in the hunt something
seen in more social hunters like
chimpanzees and the fish aren't really
taking turns though the attacks are well
timed they likely are coordinated that
might seem odd in light of these
recordings but when one is facing a
targeted swipe from a sailfish you'd
likely want to get out of the way